okay welcome back everyone so uh now
that we understand how to build a
cryptocurrency from a blockchain uh
let's see how to manage those
cryptocurrencies in what we call a
crypto wallet okay so how do we use
cryptocurrencies in the real world so
just a quick review to remind you as we
said as we looked at the blockchain
network basically um the balance of
bitcoins that i own is basically is held
in these unspent transaction outputs
that correspond to addresses that belong
to me what does belong to me mean belong
to me means that i have the secret key
that corresponds to the public key of
those addresses
now other blockchains actually don't use
the utxo model for example the ethereum
blockchain
actually has accounts where every
account
holds a value so i have again it's all
based on signatures so my i have an
account that corresponds to a public key
and a secret key but there's a value
associated with that with that account
written um on the blockchain and when i
want to spend funds i i sign a
transaction that subtracts or add funds
to the uh amounts available in the
account so it's not a collection of
utxos but rather explicit accounting
of how much money every address has yeah
so every address as we say has an
associated value and a transaction just
moves values between um between
addresses so these are kind of different
ways of representing
data on the blockchain you know either
accounts or utxos it turns out utxos
require less memory on the part of the
miners but um
but are less flexible than accounts so
for example with an account system you
could just look on the blockchain and
immediately know how much value is
associated with a particular address in
the utxo model to figure out how much
value is associated with an address you
have to go and sum up all the values of
across all utxos in the blockchains that
correspond to that address yeah so there
are trade-offs between these two ways to
represent value different blockchains as
you can see do it do it differently but
for our discussion in this segment
that's not so relevant i want to talk
about how to actually manage um those
crypto assets once you buy them okay so
just to be clear uh the crypto assets
themselves are secret are represented as
secret keys that allows you allow you to
sign transactions the question is where
do you store those secret keys and how
do you use those secret keys okay so we
do that using what we call a wallet and
what is a wallet well a wallet is
basically some client-side software that
allows us helps us manage our assets
okay so what does a wallet do well you
know it stores all of my secret signing
keys and when i want to spend
transactions when i want to spend funds
or receive funds basically um the wallet
allows me to spend funds and it also
confirms when someone send sends
funds to me
so a typical example wallet let's say
for the ethereum network is a wallet
called metamask this is kind of a fun
pro a fun system to play with i actually
suggest
download download it as a chrome
extension it's an extension that sits
inside of you inside of your browser it
basically manages um your crypto assets
and allows you to receive funds and send
funds from your address we'll see how in
just a minute so here's an example of
the user interface uh for meta mask once
you install an installer on your system
basically there's an address associated
um with this uh with this uh particular
wallet in fact you can have multiple
addresses associated with a wallet
here's one particular address that
address currently
holds one each so one if currently is a
couple hundred dollars um and the secret
keys that are needed to spend from that
from that address right remember the
secret keys are used to sign
transactions to spend funds from those
address those secret keys are basically
held on my clients so my machine
basically holds the secret keys and i
can tell metamask go ahead and send
funds somewhere and metamask will use
those secret keys to sign a transaction
to send the funds